some came by bus driving hours across
the country to gather in the peak
district but it was worth the journey to
be part of an event celebrating
diversity and calling for action
less than one percent of visitors to
national park were b-a-m-e and that's
just not good enough we make up 13 of
the population and you know the fact is
that people think like being bpoc means
living in uh urban spaces even though
there's been like a really long history
of black and asian presence in the
countryside
campaigners say people of colour aren't
always able to access the countryside
easily but they say it's not just about
how close you live to green spaces it's
also about feeling welcome there's still
many issues as many barriers
that actually hinder and prevent
communities from getting outside
islamophobia racism
is one of those that has affected our
community before
haroon motor is one of the ramblers here
he set up a group for muslim hikers
there's so much under representation for
ethnic minority communities and for
myself being a british asian muslim i've
found that growing up here i only live
down the road in coventry but i didn't
know this place existed
and that comes down to you know cultural
and lifestyle norms that don't have the
outdoors embedded within them it's for
all the people of color in this space
after some speeches the group set off
they're walking across kinder scout it's
the highest point in the peak district
and it's a symbolic site where 90 years
ago a mass trespass took place many
looked back on it as the start of a
movement that led to the foundation of
britain's national parks
hundreds of protesters descended on what
was then private land demanding access
for all some were arrested and even
jailed but almost two decades later the
peaks became public
today some feel there's still a long way
to go and want more of the country to be
accessible to all
it's a huge postcard lottery so we 92 of
the countryside is locked away you
cannot roam you cannot wonder the
government has shelved a report looking
at how much of england is open to
walkers
i think we are blessed in this country
with hundreds of thousands of miles of
our public uh footpath to allow people
to access uh the countryside and we have
to recognize that the countryside is not
just a place of leisure it is also a
place of of business and food production
the right to roam campaign has more
action planned across the country they
say lockdown highlighted the physical
and mental benefits of being close to
nature and they want more people to be
able to spend time in the wild becky
kotchel sky news the peak district